éloigné de sa famille
l'homme marié redevenu célibataire doit
avant toute chose pour garder son moral
se substanter mais il n'est pas question
pour lui de passer de la cuisine à la
salle à manger
cela est bon lorsque l'on ne se gêne
avec sa femme et ses enfants pendant le
mois de juillet au mois d'août la
liberté est totale
voici quelques méthodes et quelques
accommodements la vaisselle lave
vaisselle terreur du célibataire et bien
vous avez maintenant sur les trois
quarts des évier de cuisine une surface
de séchage qui certes peut-être n'est
peut-être pas très décorative mais et à
présente les mêmes caractéristiques que
les cabanes dans lesquelles nous avons
mangé alarmé par an deux ans alors quand
vous avez par exemple un plat les là et
bien sur cette surface bien nettoyer
d'ailleurs il vous est fort possible de
manger sans voyez ce serait quoi
un jean chagneau l'achète départements
voisins comme le définit pour passer au
plat cheminement mon dieu crayssac un
coup voilà vous prenez un tuyau branchez
vous nettoyer la surface
voilà et vous avez à nouveau une
assiette propre peut-être un peu unir
mais il vous est pas interdit de
l'assécher voilà et vous pouvez
facilement passer au plat suivant
et bien c'est une chose qui mon dieu est
très simple ne vous oblige à aucun
déménagement et vous permet d'ouvrir et
de vue l'autre [ __ ] cales sont embêtés
par personne le problème de la boisson
est pas question d premier les verts il
doit par il faut boire frais alors vous
mettez la bouteille de vin dans un bac
glacé avec un tuyau vous avez à votre
disposition sans bouger
du vin à volonté et vous suffit
d'inspirer ça mais il fallait y penser
le problème du pain n'est pas allé
chercher du pain tous les jours j'en
prenais pourquoi quatre jours seulement
évidemment il a tendance à durcir alors
pourquoi ne pas utiliser ce que votre
femme a laissé vous est très facile
d'avoir eu près et vous avec cet
appareil là en quelques instants un
toast chaud et délicieux comme dans les
meilleurs salons de thé suisse vous
pouvez même ajouter du beurre ou de la
confiture de toute façon ça ne fera
jamais que le tissu a changé et là vous
avez un toast croustillant à souhait
voilà donc heureux qu'arne recule pas
ennuyer alors le problème évidemment des
jeunes ont vaincu lindsay la chaleur et
bien si vous prenez la précaution que
j'ai prise ou d'installer un système de
deir conditionné si vous avez trop chaud
un simple pression est automatiquement
l'air conditionné pas d'être dans la
cuisine
[Musique]